[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
talking about forms in Aikido and how
forms are a collection of techniques and
not techniques in and of themselves now
that might seem like a funny and
specific distinction but it's a really
important distinction to make because we
tend to think that an Aikido form is
actually the way you're going to use
Aikido and we also tend to think that
that whatever happens at the end of the
form is the objective of Aikido
technique when in fact it's generally
the lowest percentage technique that we
have Aikido is filled with all kinds of
techniques and things that we don't even
often thinker techniques and we're going
to illustrate some of those in the form
we're about to show but it's important
understand those techniques are really
similar to techniques you would find in
martial arts from all kinds of other
cultures that are dealing with the same
context generally the context is one in
which someone has something in their
hand and that's probably going to be
some weapon of some sort if we're
talking about physical conflict and why
someone would be holding a hand or
swinging a hand or something like that
spell because there's a weapon in that
hand so the form we're gonna look at
today is katate dori Shiho nage and I'm
gonna get Josh out here we're gonna go
to work Josh all right so this week
we're talking about breaking the forms
down so when you see an Aikido form most
of us tend to make the mistake of
calling that form a technique and you
need to understand the form is actually
filled with techniques so there are a
ton of techniques in there so a form is
a tactical or strategic practice that
has a collection of techniques and we're
answering a bunch of different things
that could happen in any situation so
when you look at a form you tend to
think that the end goal in the idea of
that form is to get to the end and
instead it's generally teaching you that
the end is the worst thing that could
possibly happen so right now we're going
to talk about katate dori
Shiho nage
all right so in katate dori co nage we
start with a katate dori now this is a
little bit outside the scope of this
video but I kind of want to talk about
why the top they'd already exist so you
can understand why that might exist
right so let's say this guy broke into
my house late at night and I had a
weapon in my hand and I'm planning to
use the weapon this guy's surprised me
right because our first Aikido goal good
Aikido would be keeping distance from
this guy so he could never get near me
um but you know maybe he came out around
the corner or who knows what and he sees
that I have a weapon in my hand so the
second he sees that if he shoots down he
grabs it and he's gonna be attacking my
face somehow right so when you see this
all of a sudden that makes sense because
we didn't do that right so if he just
came in to hit my face I'm gonna be
doing this right so it's a bad trade for
him because when I naturally go like
this then I'm gonna load him up with
this knife so he needs to check that
weapon hand now for me to clear this
weapon hand is absolutely essential I
have to have methods to quickly clear
this weapon hand so that would be the
situation if I needed that technique
which is the top de Tori to defend
against it could also be that he's gonna
draw a weapon and when he does that I
don't want him to right so I'm stopping
him from drawing that weapon so maybe
I'm talking to this guy on the street
somewhere and I think everything's cool
and all of a sudden he makes a quick
action I go oh no way man now this isn't
gonna be it right this isn't the end of
the technique this is just a way to
suppress his hand so I could hit him in
the face or do whatever it is get to my
weapon platform whatever does I need to
do to stop this guy but that's where it
starts and that's the first technique in
this form so people have a tendency to
out of hand just going
why would someone ever grab your wrist
and or that's not a technique that's
just a silly position that we get into
to practice the actual technique but
that is the first technique in this form
okay now we've got a guy who's holding
my hand likely because I have something
in it that I want to use alright so now
I have a weapon in my hand and I want to
use it the first thing I have to be
aware of is there's something coming on
this side of his body right so he's
gonna be smashing me doing something so
that means I want to move away from this
side so I would like to move here right
now that's what I want to do I want to
get that nice clear like that boom to
get back to the back side that's what
I'm looking for right so I'm here like
this and I want to turn now we see our
second technique or maybe a third
depending how you want to count it
because the soap-bubble War II is a
technique and the hadou key I'm going to
be using is also a technique so here I'm
trying to rotate that wrist and clear it
now why you get that I can cut this guy
and go about my business which is what I
need to do right so protect my family or
whatever the situation is we're in so
I'm trying to free this weapon hand
while moving to the safe direction so if
he's attacking me on that line I'm
moving away from that line while I'm
clear my weapon hand and trying to get
to a superior position alright now if I
turn and he can keep a hold of me he's
going to so meaning when I turn he's
gonna sit right to me
right can you see this classically get
this now if you could he's gonna come
around hit me in bang if he's gonna do
it grab me attacked me the winner so
when I turned he's gonna turn so one of
the things I could do is continue my
turn like this right so when we get in
that position like that then I can use
my weapon on him now I'm trying to be
delicate so I don't jab Josh in the eye
here but understand that what I'm doing
is I'm going like this was coming back
behind I'm getting into this position
and now my weapons highly effective
again right so all I'm doing is
continuing my turn to put the weapon
away so I don't risk getting Josh as I
I'm gonna move a little faster here I go
like this right that's the idea now look
at what Josh did he decided he didn't
want to hold on anymore because balance
was compromised so took the fall anyways
he's a good Aikido guy but if you notice
he let go of my wrist a lot of times
when we see that in the form we go oh
but what if they let go of your wrist
okay let's say we're in this position I
turn back there and Josh lets go of my
wrist what was my original objective to
get my weapon hand free is my weapon
hand free yes am i in a good position
certainly right
this is devily position where I could
begin to use my weapon again right so so
understand that in Aikido when we're
trying to get the form done and someone
let's go you you go all that technique
doesn't work it's not a technique it's a
form and in fact the technique worked
exactly like it was supposed to work
right it was it's job is to clear this
hand so if I turn and this hand clears
that's exactly what I wanted now I can
use it let's say it doesn't clear though
so this guy's got a really good grip and
I turn on a heat
turning and I get back here like this
now my weapons here at his neck right so
I could
start to use that weapon at the neck
like this let's say he pushes it back so
I can't no I can't quite get to his neck
and pushing it back he has put himself
into the bad position right here right
which is the shield I get position I
enter in behind this and we get the fall
right technique one-hand grab technique
to this Hadopi if that didn't work
technique three the Shiho nage technique
for tenkai kote 'gosh and the takedown
here now let's say we're in this
situation here and he's still got my
weapon hand I need to know how to escape
with my weapon hand so we look right
here there's a Kota guys built into the
shyona yang that helps me escape so I
could get my weapon hand free if I
needed to say I grabbed him here aim
like this to stop him now what do I want
to do I want to get away from that hand
he's gonna hit me with that hand so I
turned here like that I get back to this
back position right here from this back
position I start working to hit this
knife free once I get the knife free I'm
in good position so this form is full of
techniques so don't think that the form
is a technique in itself it's just a
form it's a collection of techniques
that are answering a set of questions
that keep coming up and up and up
this is katate dori
[Music]